We have a corona virus stimulus deal that
has finally been reached, and as some of you
might have heard on my livestreams, every
day there's like three proposals floated and
maybe it's going to happen.
Maybe it's not.
And then it gets canceled or replaced with
something else.
So because we all along, if I had talked about
every possible deal, the entire show would
have been just possible deals.
That didn't become a reality.
We just decided we're going to wait and then
we'll discuss the deal once it's actually
done.
The priorities for me are we've got to bail
people out.
People with bills, people with expenses, people
who need money and may no longer have a job.
We've got to do something about small business.
Very, very important because a lot of small
businesses can't weather this.
I'm talking to small business owners all the
time in my neighborhood and other neighborhoods
in Boston who say, you know, I can make 30
percent of what I was making before.
But the problem is my rent is 40 percent.
So I need something.
I need some kind of bridge to get me there.
And you want to provide capital strategically
to reduce interruptions of different kinds,
prevent the unemployment rate from exploding
as much as it would without some incentive
for small businesses to keep people on, etc..
This is the largest stimulus package in American
history.
Now, a stimulus package, the concept of a
stimulus package is it's a Keynesian idea.
The idea being government spending can lessen
the severity of a recession.
Stimulate the economy.
Boost employment.
Boost spending.
That's the framework.
It's a Keynesian framework.
We're talking about this deal was reached
just hours ago, around 1:30 a.m.
Eastern Time, very early this morning.
Here is Republican Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell announcing it at last.
We have a deal.
After days of intense discussions, the Senate
has reached a bipartisan agreement on a Head
Start relief package for this pandemic.
It will rush new resources onto the front
lines of our nation's health care fight, and
it will inject trillions of dollars of cash
into the economy as fast as possible.
As you can tell there, Mitch McConnell just
overwhelmed with emotion over this historic
deal.
So what's in it?
Some of the details are still being worked
out.
Some of the language is still being written.
As of as of this second.
But here's what we have so far.
It'll be a two trillion dollar stimulus package.
People individuals earning up to $75000 in
income will get a 12 hundred dollar One-Time
check.
Couples double the money for double the income
limit.
Twenty four hundred dollars.
If as a couple you earn up to 150000.
You get an additional $500 per child based
on what we saw an hour ago.
Again, some of the final details may change.
The twelve hundred dollar check starts to
phase out as you approach ninety nine thousand
dollars in income as an individual or one
hundred ninety eight thousand as a couple.
And once you get to that level ninety nine
K per person, you lose the 12, you lose all
the money, you get zero after that point.
Unemployment insurance will be expanded to
include people that are furloughed, gig workers,
freelancers.
Right.
People that would not normally qualify for
unemployment insurance.
They will also be adding.
And this is one of the things that's a probably.
But we don't know for sure yet.
It looks like they're going to increase the
unemployment payments by six hundred bucks
a week for four months above the state base.
Different states unemployment insurance is
state based.
So the benefit in Massachusetts may be different
from the benefit in Florida or in California.
That'll be upped by six hundred bucks a week
by the federal government.
There will be an employee retention tax credit
for businesses to keep people on.
So we've seen two versions between 25 and
$50 billion for passenger airlines, between
four and eight billion for cargo airlines,
17 billion for companies determined to be
important to national security.
The details, of course, still remain to be
determined there, roughly $500 billion in
a corporate liquidity program.
These would be loans to businesses through
banks.
Very important to understand that would be
through banks.
And then another 367 billion, roughly through
a small business loan program, through the
Small Businesses Association, 30 billion in
education funding, 25 billion in transit funding.
So this is the bulk of it.
Now, there's a question about the income limit
on the twelve hundred dollar check 75k.
What's the process and verification of that?
If it's based on 2019 income, a lot of people
haven't filed their 20 19 tax returns.
So what happens there?
We don't know.
There's the idea that you would use twenty
eighteen income if you've not yet filed your
2019 tax return.
Excuse me.
Could that be gamed in some way?
We don't know.
But this is part of the details.
Well, that still needs to be worked out.
Another question is how does this impact self-employed
people?
There are some other specifics that need to
be sorted out, but it's finally happening.
It's happening far too late.
It's happening after a lot of personal financial
damage has already happened to people who
have been laid off for one week, two weeks,
even longer in some cases.
Chuck Schumer, Senate minority leader, says
that Trump's businesses will not be eligible
for any of this stuff.
That's an assertion from Chuck Schumer.
I've not yet seen any language that makes
that clear.
This is the framework we have so far in the
background of all this.
Donald Trump increase increasingly wants to
reopen everything or close to everything on
Easter Sunday, April 12th.
I want to talk about that next.
And we'll be doing sort of deeper dove into
that a little bit later
in
the program.